3 oui oui oui on me dit on me dit que
l'invité est arrivé j'ai vu la coupe est
là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
toi on va parler de toi toi là la junte
aurait répondu l'espionné j'ai plein de
choses à dire je te jure un alors m6 a
alors alors c'est la petite qui les
auront la capitale ça cartonne
mais quand tu prends la place et si vite
tu dois moment donné c'est génial
d'imiter patrick sébastien lord y en a
qui reliait dakar i fé mettetal est
ouverte rochambeau bon à prendre c'est
le but dans les arénas il est apparu
mais c'est marseille avait un peu de de
françois mitterrand m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
oui c'est moi embrasser christian
mais avec nunavik devrait tous nous
arrive à bien ce qui va se passer dans
quelques instants
l élégant a toujours aimé regarder ça et
franchement les deux là regardez
regardez kim de l'aller 2 2 puis à peu
près pareil que j'ai gardées on dirait
du sarkozy fillon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous connaissez bien confessions at il
inventé c'est pas gerra qui inventaient
confessions intimes est une production
d'une société qui s'appelle qu'issus de
dakar dont j'étais propriétaire et c'est
grâce à cette émission pour la première
fois j'ai monté ma boîte de prod donc
j'allais réinventer les générations que
tout le monde est très fier d'avoir
inventé cette
vous êtes très bobo et d'ailleurs je lui
dit alors en loge ses voiries le courbet
a passé un cap au niveau du physique
vous n'avez pas dit tout à fait comme ça
mais c'était j'ai des petites loges du
tout elle est belle la courbette ce soir
à quoi bon c'est vrai la poubelle
[Musique]
oui que la vie c'est u2
i
donc une coupe de champagne ou un verre
dans la gueule [ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
alerte donc tu n'es week-end à lui bien
j'étais au musée c'est de quelques sur
le quai d orsay
ouais non eh bien mon tableau préféré de
tous les tableaux
à l'origine c'est pas lui c'est julien
courbet à l'uni
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
lacroix
[Applaudissements]
m
comment mes lunettes c'est une tâche
dont le titre du programme un peu rock'n
roll auquel on a pensé ses courbes et
vous pisse à la raie oui j'ai dit à
julien je voulais te dire un truc je
voulais te dire vraiment tu vas je te
dit tu vas beaucoup me manquer parce que
j'adorais quand et autour de la table tu
m'as remplacer le vendredi c'était
exceptionnel et a fait des cartons
d'audience vraiment quand est arrivée
sur la chaîne je me rappelle très bien
je tape à appeler un samedi matin
c'est vrai je me rappelle qu'ils étaient
en vacances je sais plus haut à l'autre
bout du monde et je t'avais dit julien
vraiment je rêverais que tu viennes sur
s'est vite quand tu m'as dit oui j'étais
le plus heureux du monde parce que tu
sais que j'ai toujours été très fan de
toi notamment à la radio sur rtl parce
que tu t'étais juste avant jean pierre
et moi et c'est vrai que pour moi tu es
parti je te le dis vraiment des 3 4 et
je dis franchement meilleur animateur
que j'aie jamais rencontré
vraiment je te dire en impro tu peux
tout faire tu peux faire du magazine tu
peux faire du divertissement
tu peux faire du jeu pour moi tu es
vraiment un exemple je te le dis et je
voulais dire une dernière chose on peut
aussi se quitter sans se déchirer
exactement s'insultent et à dire à se
faire des procès simplement en étant
amis et je pense que je serai toute la
vie à cette famille et j'y reviendrai
j'espère pression
[Musique]